you've been in Hollywood for a long time
as this stuff is as as weird for you as
it is for us or you one of the guys that
are like yeah I kind of knew this was
happening
no I didn't know a Weinstein when I
first got famous which is like
ninety-two Weinstein Harvey Weinstein
was just becoming Harvey Weinstein so
the company was like you know it's just
making their bones so to speak but I
can't remember what it was but it was
there was a there was something he
wanted when I first met him it was
something he wanted to for me to do for
his company some movie like it was like
a beam action movie or something and I
didn't know the guy and he walked up and
you know within seconds he presented
himself as a bullet you know it's the
stomach was hanging out he had a
cigarette gala he's going like yeah I'm
Harvey Weinstein You Know Who I am and I
want you to do that and I was like I'm
not doing that and they kept you're
gonna do it because my company and I can
I can make a break your career and I was
like go [ __ ] yourself he was saying that
90 day yeah so but you know I knew he
was a bully so I said I'm not [ __ ]
doing it pal and as soon as I said I'm
not [ __ ] doing it like the second
time he was like I'm buying all your
drinks and from that moment on every
time I ran into the guy he was a nicest
guy in the world to me really but he was
an [ __ ] to a lot of [ __ ] people
did you wind up doing the movie or no I
did a movie for now I didn't do the
movie but I did a couple movies for his
company I never had a problem with him
ran into him here and there and I'll
sure whatever because he was a [ __ ]
bully and once you push them back right
it's like any bully he's like hey now
we're best friend right right I didn't
know I didn't know you know I knew his
reputation for a womanizer whatever I
didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't have to deal
with the guy yeah and there's enough
guys that [ __ ] different girl it's like
womanizing is one thing if a guy cheats
right his business it's like that I love
when these things these guys were by the
way this Avalanche is [ __ ] happening
big-time now so there was yeah like
Toback now it's all it's just all gonna
[ __ ] roll out which I think as a
result of Trump winning the election so
I think that although Trump not to make
a pun he had the trump card on Hillary
when we all remember where we were on
grab the [ __ ] weekend sure on that
Friday so you know he Bill Clinton's
sexual history was [ __ ] solved that
by the time that Sunday night debate
happened so from Friday what everybody
were saying oh he's out he's done he's
cooked he just used the you know Bill
Clinton's sexual history against them
right so anyways I think from that
moment
on this thing has turned into a snowball
I think now more and more guys are gonna
get busted on this [ __ ] I think it's
great guys I got power that we're [ __ ]
with people underneath them yeah roger
ailes to bill o'reilly with the one like
once you guys went people like oh my god
leave if you can get roger ailes out of
fox
yeah same thing you could say about
harvey weinstein right here i only dealt
with them in a certain lobo you have no
[ __ ] idea what's going on behind the
scene and you're not the guy we're not
the people that he's gonna be at like
I'm not the guy that's gonna be asked to
give a massage like you I mean I'm not
gonna see that side of them ever so it's
only like when you don't see yeah they
seem fine like we had Harvey once I
don't know him that it's fine of course
he was he was selling the movies not
gonna come in and go by the way I've
been putting my dick in women's faces
for 30 years yeah he's not going to
admit that in the drink to see me shower
gym yeah what a crazy man what a crazy
follow up - no I won't massage you [ __ ]
yeah well that's a great gift thanks
coach [ __ ] a plate it's one of those
things reader when it first came out you
had to read the article like three times
cuz I like Travers never ever be like no
no I'm pretty sure it says he would
watch them showers right no that makes
sense yeah and you know watch me shower
this says he would have the actresses
wouldn't that [ __ ] look I mean that
is who the [ __ ] even his doctor doesn't
want to see him think his [ __ ] oh my god
no you can leave the shirt on I was bad
by the way what he's he's dead he's dead
in the water he can't come back into the
you know show business so unless he's
gonna do once he gets a podcast on The
O'Reilly Network well okay by the way
there's an idea yeah okay if they had a
[ __ ] talk show those two guys their
audience would follow them to that you
know to me or even like you know Bill
O'Reilly in the mornings Harvey
Weinstein afternoon yes listen and
listen let's get a line of products
loofas [ __ ] you know how Sasha well
yeah massage oil
shower gel body in the shower Congress I
like the habits about showering that
those to Christ like they would just
click ah my god man I get shitty [ __ ]
awesome awesome parties hoping for a
second chance he's no of course not he's
dead